le cinquième c'est les chéris le
cinquième
merci le temps que ça se mette en place
et Guillaume
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que vous êtes tous aussi
je le dis parce que ça me gêne numéro 4
numéro 4 numéro 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci podium
en troisième position des chroniqueurs
de l'année on a tout pris en compte
c'est
Jules
[Musique]
après merci beaucoup
que ce soit donc
forcément il en reste deux
qui est à la deuxième place des
chroniqueurs de l'année deuxième place
c'est
[Musique]
bravo Mathieu merci avant de les numéros
je voudrais dire Bernard tu as fait une
amie magnifique franchement et on espère
que tu seras avec nous l'année prochaine
ce que tu as été tué on rigole tout le
temps ensemble et je trouve vraiment je
me régale quand tu es là moi tu sais
bien sûr que tu es indispensable à
l'émission ma chérie et c'est un bonheur
de t'avoir à mes côtés et c'est vrai que
Valérie et Bernard ils prennent moins de
place dans les débats et comme on vient
beaucoup de débats forcément
on va considérer que vous êtes numéro 2
toutes les deux
Jean-Michel tu as été là deuxième partie
de la saison exceptionnelle vraiment
travaille pas non mais je te dis
tu as été exceptionnel mon chéri est
vraiment je peux te dire tu vas
titulaire indiscutable l'année prochaine
mon Hugo tu as un nouveau venu et toi
vraiment tu m'as révélation de l'année
mon bébé tu sais que on va passer des
bons moments tous les deux que ce soit à
mykono que sur le plateau Kelly elle a
toujours la phrase qu'il faut et son
avis représente très souvent la vie du
public et c'est vrai qu'il y a fait une
année exceptionnelle aussi cette année
donc vraiment bravo à toi et tu es à
côté de mon chouchou maintenant donc mes
deux chouchous voilà ne me décevez pas
l'année prochaine mais je sais que vous
me décevrez pas et que vous allez être
excellent en tout cas vous avez fait une
très belle année et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que vous serez avec nous
encore l'année prochaine bien entendu et
c'est vrai que voilà vous deux voilà je
vous dis je pense que là on tient un
beau du haut voilà alors je sais qu'il y
a juste un problème de localisation
toi
ça ferait plaisir de prendre
du soutien avec Hugo d'accord
[Applaudissements]
Sophie ma chérie toi aussi alors pas
souvent là mais quand tu es là tu fais
beaucoup parler de toi et l'année
prochaine tu seras beaucoup plus souvent
avec nous ma chérie et bien vous l'avez
compris le chroniqueur de l'année c'est
bien entendu regardez
[Applaudissements]
bravo mon Raymond mon frérot je suis
très heureux
parce que c'est compliqué cette année
cette année c'est compliqué Valérie elle
a vu aussi parce que comme j'ai perdu
mon papa j'avais fait le début de la
saison où j'allais j'allais à l'hôpital
et je venais ici après donc ça a été
très très difficile on en a parlé aussi
ensemble et et il m'a dit avant de
partir il m'a dit reste avec Hanouna il
est gentil avec toi
donc je suis content si me regarde de
là-haut bah il doit dire au moins il est
premier quelque part
[Applaudissements]
il doit être fier de toi comme moi je le
suis je sais que je suis fier de toi tu
es mon ami mon frère dans la vie et
c'est vrai que tu as été tu as fait une
annexe exceptionnelle et sache qu'avec
les équipes on t'a écrit une chanson
on t'a écrit une chanson et ce soir
j'aurais demandé à Émile et image et
bien vouloir venir nous rejoindre car
c'est une chanson pour toi ça va être le
feu c'est on a refait les paroles pour
Raymond on va mettre même la mettre en
place pour peut-être la mettre sur des
plateformes etc c'est un tube énorme on
va laisser Émilie et image venez là
merci merci Monsieur c'est énorme parce
que ils ont fait ils ont joué le jeu à
fond et ils ont vraiment enregistré la
chanson ils l'ont fait c'est incroyable
c'est pour Raymond le chroniqueur de
l'année c'est parti chanter chez ma
tante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut chanter tout le monde
je peux pas sortir
[Musique]
j'ai la livraison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde une fille qui se tait
lui dit 300 mon petit pour la nuit
blanche
[Musique]
méfiez-vous que
[Applaudissements]
la nuit
jusqu'à la naissance
qui regarde une fille qui se délin
méfiez-vous
de vivre c'est un chroniqueur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo
merci parce que ils ont joué le jeu à
fond quand vous êtes des amours encore
17 décembre 2023 car en rédaction
tournée
ils font des concerts avec des milliers
de personnes et ils ont joué qu’on les
appeler très très fort
merci vraiment merci merci ils étaient à
fond merci vous êtes vraiment des amours
et Raymond et on va et on va la sortir
cela
tu vas faire la tournée des boîtes
ah mais celui c'est sûr ah ben stop ne
touche pas à mon poste ben oui et tu
sais l'anecdote ma tante avec Catherine
elle chantait amour sauvage maîtresse
sur ma maîtresse elle chantait elle
avait un petit studio et tout elle
voulait à tout près de chanteuse donc si
elle me regarde tata Catherine j'ai
chanté sur votre chanson quand j'étais
petit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]